[Music]
right through the city like British I'm
on a mission to get it all right through
the city like British if you ain't thick
please don't get involved
now Brandon
what is up fam it is Monday February
13th Monday morning live not really live
but by the time you listen to this
definitely not live but you know what
I'm saying we are here at thick boy
stews in calabas California
quite the weekend fam quite the weekend
for the fight fans and football fans yet
Super Bowl weekend hope you all enjoyed
that Super Bowl uh Patrick Mahoney's
doing the damn thing and then you also
had the big UFC 284
um I mean the main event in UFC 284
delivered and the Super Bowl delivered
so can't be mad at any of it unless
you're a Philadelphia Eagles fan or
you're uh Alexander wilkinowski fan even
if you are Alexander volkonovsky fan you
should be too upset the way he performed
I thought he won the story of the night
but lost the fight to the judges so uh
we'll get into that especially with the
pound-for-pound rankings I don't think
he should lose a spot and we will get
into that I am fresh off the plane from
Austin Texas where I did a food truck
diary with Gordon Ryan
and um I can't say enough about Gordon
Ryan he is such a freaking good dude
such a good dude man he was right away
we're buddies right away we're buddies
Casey was out there Casey did a great
job we did it uh was it CM CM
Smokehouse and uh yeah Gordon Ryan's a
special dude man really special dude and
just
instant friends man instant friends
we're gonna roll and then
um my schedule got busy that would have
been a nightmare for me who'd have tied
me in a million knots
um and he's a big car guy and we're
talking about this Viper he talks about
on the food truck the special vipers you
can get after he wins his next Jiu Jitsu
uh match and uh yeah we're just chatting
about cars one of my favorite uh food
trucks
let me talk about the greatest Jiu Jitsu
practitioner of all time as far as no
ghee goes man as far as nogi goes now
there's some lighter weights that could
have an argument for the best ever but
as far as big guys go there's it's not
even close he is such a Savage so I had
such a good time with him I text him
after because he has a stomach condition
if you're familiar with going right you
know what I'm talking about he talks a
little bit about it on the food truck
diary and uh he has to be careful what
he eats so do I with my psoriasis so
it's barbecue
um and he just ordered a straight up
cheeseburger and fries I was like I feel
like this is a bad idea he's like no I
should be fine and all night I was
losing sleepover next one I take some
how we feeling he's like I'm good man
I'm telling you I'm good I'm on these
you know strong
um medication that I can eat this stuff
now so thank God man but he was he was
such a good dude it's a good one man
he's a great great guy man great guy
about
220-ish 225 you know I I think everyone
you know they'll try to devalue and go
oh the only reason he wins because he's
so much bigger than everyone no he's not
a matter of fact the guys that he's
fighting they're bigger than him usually
you know how about 260 270 240 250s he's
about 220ish he's also compromised
because he's constantly nauseous and not
at his full capabilities that's how
special the guy is so now is he fighting
the top Jutsu competition in the world
but he's doing it hindered with his
condition insane insane man it'd be like
if Michael Jordan just had the flu all
the time it's still balled out that's
this guy such a good person man
so that drops when we drop that when
Thursday
Wednesday or Thursday this week we'll
say Thursday for now
we'll say Thursday for now
um so yeah so I went out there to do the
food truck with Gordon Ryan
and then also the fight campaign UFC 284
with Joe Rogan Brian count and Eddie
Bravo the original OG crew is back it's
available right now it's available right
freaking now
um on Spotify it was live on JRE YouTube
and then uh it's available on Spotify
now where it gets uploaded uh the full
episodes upload there it was a fun one
man I'd say the most straight up fight
talk we've ever done on that show
usually talking about octopus or you
know chimpanzees or some wild [__] but
uh this is a very fight focus and I
think it's kudos to the card is a
fantastic card especially the main card
the prelims a little tough you know
you're like yeah is this gonna be one of
those nights but um man that that main
card it got it got popping you know the
Jimmy crew Alonso menifield fight uh
started off Alonzo has to be kicking
himself you know with um the point
deduction because she'll won that fight
he won two rounds to one for sure but
with the point deduction get a draw and
then uh Justin taffa with the KO didn't
get a bonus which he can't be happy
about uh Justin topper with the walk-off
home run
in a minute
knocked out Peter Parker porker
um doing the damn thing and then uh yeah
you know what I'm saying yeah and then
uh not the MVP of the night but he's the
chance of this kid holding gold is
pretty high at welterweight uh Jack
Della is Jackie boy got it done and I
think a lot of people with Randy Brown
because it was jack's first really tough
fight you know he's he had his win in
the Dana White's Contender series and
he's had four finishes leading up to
Randy Brown Randy Brown's no punk and
he's a tough
tough night in the office for anyone
especially at his size at 6'3 at
welterweight and his reach was a little
difficult and kind of hard to navigate
but for Jack and I think people were
like Man Randy band's kind of doing the
damn thing and Jack could be in some
trouble here Jack's from Perth I mean
he's a Perth boy that's his hometown so
if there was a lot of pressure on Jack
and then as soon I I don't think it was
a matter of Randy Brown's that much
better than Jack I think Jack it just
shows the fight IQ that he has we just
waited waited for the perfect time and
then boom two minutes in landed against
the octagon and just put him out on his
face and then choked him out with a rare
naked choke but I'm telling you this
Jack dude is a special talent man
special special talent then he got
straight to the Cobain event main event
doing the companions you know we usually
sometimes four or five hours by the time
you got to that Coleman event like we
were like oh damn we're only like an
hour and 40 minutes into this damn thing
I was like this could be a quick one and
then uh yeah Rodriguez Joshua Emmett you
know I picked Josh Emma to win this
fight I thought his
just his age his experience
um his meat and potatoes
um kind of technique and his power uh
I'm I'm a fan of yair I'm just haven't
been fully sold just like I wasn't on
Islam
um even with the Charles Olivera fight
because his threat to schedule I'm not
sold completely
um and that's how I was a little bit
like that with yair right his biggest
fights Frankie Edgar
um max Holloway he lost so I thought
Josh Emmett might pose some issues for
him you know he did beat Brian Ortega
but
via submission but even that was a
little controversial before that I lost
Max Holloway beat Jeremy Stevens long on
the tooth right
um he had that KO with a minute with a
second left against Korean zombie and
then before they lost Frankie Edgar he
made a very old BJ pen strength schedule
I'm big on strength to schedule I was
never I'm never that sold it takes a lot
to win me over so
um I did think it was a fair bet to bet
on Josh Emmett I ended up losing that
bet yair Rodriguez looked fantastic his
kicks and we were just sucking them off
we were just sucking that Mexican
cortada out of Yaya Rodriguez because
the way he would kick and Then followed
up with the punches he looked phenomenal
phenomenal man that submission that
triangle choke was fantastic thank God
that happened because you do want to see
Alexander volkonovski back at
featherweight now because yair is on
this straight surge what he did Josh
Emmett now you don't feel as bad for uh
vocalypse coming back down there's a
great story there but when we get to the
main event with mock Jeff and wokenovsky
you know watching it
um with the companion crew obviously
we're drinking obviously we're under the
influence of a few uh things
um but we watched that fight you know we
watch we're usually we're talking and
bullshitting we'll miss things this one
we really pay attention to but again we
are compromised with alcohol and other
devices so I never
put too much weight in how we feel and
our decisions that night but I feel like
we kind of got this one there's an
argument we got this one right I posted
on my Instagram uh our reaction you can
play that chin
[Music]
this is [__] incredible Brandon shop
oh my God
look at this 35 seconds ago all he has
to do is not get submitted and stay on
top and he's the [__] double
channels I mean even compromise though
you know Rogan seemed more
people get punched the face say what so
you know even when Rogan's on that train
I mean Eddie didn't say much but he
thought he won Brian's you know just all
over the place and but Brian did get
some stuff right
you know my my reason for picking
volcanovsky in this fight is just
I think we underestimated his Champion
mentality that Mamba mentality and you
know the guy has a lot to find how long
the last time he lost he fought freaking
it was a David Goliath type of situation
so him going to that fight he legit
thought he could win I think the fight
which to me one of the greatest UFC
fights of all time the pound for round
number one in his Prime versus pound for
pound number two also I and here's the
here's what scare I don't think machev
has reached his prime or potential yet
yeah I think he's there's still a lot
more for him to do which is scary but
I do think that both of these gentlemen
which made it for a great fight
underestimate each other where
volkanovsky underestimated uh makshev
striking and makshev underestimated
volkanovsky's some uh grappling
so you got this stand-up War
and
you you had some grappling I think that
the Grappa is
what ended up giving much of the
decision with the judges
you know I think on the companion again
heavy Under the Influence are you a
robbery I hate robberies I don't think
he was a robbery there's never robbers
but re-watch it there's a I and I said
this in the campaign I went hey are we
just biased because we're going it's a
David Goliath type of situation we've
been drinking freaking whiskey and we
and you know going into the fight so
many people big name people in this
business go Macho's gonna slice through
him like butter Eddie said that Brian
said that Josh uh my boy uh Josh
Thompson said that anybody who's
familiar with my chef goes he's gonna
walk through this guy
so do you kind of side more with
volkanasi because he didn't get what get
ran through out in any capacity he it
was a good fight but when you take that
out of it you take the hype out of it
you take the biasy out of it and you
look at that fight as just a a normal
viewer without the bias and let's say
that vocalowski was a true 155 or an
Islam was a 155 or true 155 version you
take all the bias out would you still
squirt for volcanovsky I don't know
but doesn't matter that really doesn't
matter because it is Alexander
volkanovski coming up the 55 fighting
not only a 55er but a gigantic 55er
who's eventually going to 170 and become
a double champ there to a triple champ
for that well double champ because he
didn't get the 145 title but he'll be
you know a champion at 170 if he wants
to because he's a huge 55er
so when it comes to the to the judging
you know I do think the judges that gave
four rounds of one I think that's a
little extreme three to two is fair
depending how you score it it all
depends I score the second fourth round
the second or fourth is where this fight
was determined you know the fifth
Claire's day the for the first Claire's
day the third you know
um he
the third you should probably give it to
volkanovsky right so if you give
vocalowski the third and the fifth
that's easy you'd have to find him
around in one two and four the fourth
round
gets a little dicey because although
volkonowski is being controlled which is
dominant position when he had that body
lock
ski was Landing shots there but he was
still being controlled and they weren't
significant shots
so depending on how you view fighting
you could give vocalypse that fourth
round but most likely 99 of the time
you're not going to give a guy despite
uh it being a smaller guy fighting a
bigger guy you're probably not going to
give to volkanovski because he's being
controlled there's a compromised
position it is a dominant position a
body lock even though Mark Jeff wasn't
doing much with it but again the only
reason this argument here is because
you're going I thought he's gonna slice
through him I thought he's gonna destroy
him but he put up a great fight and we
realized how good voknowski is on the
ground my god dude good luck at 45
beating him let's take a little break
because this episode of the shop Show
Breaking Down UFC 284 volkanasi bakchev
quite the controversy all right and this
episode of the shaab show is brought to
you by better help all right better help
better help is here to help you guys out
it's in the name when you're at your
best you can do great things but
sometimes life gets you bogged down you
may feel overwhelmed or like you're not
showing up up in the way that you want
to well working with a therapist can
help you get closer to the best version
of you because when you feel empowered
you're more prepared to take on
everything life throws at you throws a
bunch of curveballs you never know
what's coming all right if you're
thinking of giving therapy a try better
help is a great option it's convenient
flexible affordable and it's entirely
online to fill out a brief questionnaire
to get matched with a licensed therapist
switch therapist anytime you want no
additional charge if you want to live a
more empowered life therapy can get you
there visit betterhelp.com shop schab
today to get temps off your first month
that's betterhelp help help.com job
betterhelp.com
this episode is also brought to you by
happy hippo Kratom listen listen gang I
only recommend products that I
personally only use it's the only way
you can get on the show this is one I
use not only for this show but all the
time stand up in life I'm talking about
happy hippo Kratom the only Kratom that
I trust this stuff helps me tackle my
crazy ass schedule and it helps me get
stuff done that's honestly the best way
to describe it helps you get stuff done
A to B get it done pretty black and
white it's not just some sort of random
drink you use to get energy no no it
helps with the Mind helps you think
clearly helps you put form sentences
helps with all that stuff you get a nice
warm balance good mood feeling my
favorites are the the shots they have
the butterscotch shot the high
concentrate shot they have the Cherry
shot I only use the shots right now but
they offer gummies powders but I prefer
the shots all right the shots are
fantastic their Kratom is a Hidden Gem
it's your Limitless
little shot all right all you got to do
is go to happyhippo.com promo code is
thick with 3cs
t-h-i-c-c-c-c 23 and you get 20 off for
life as many times as you want use it
keep using it happyhippo.com promo code
is thick 23 thick with three C's thick
happyhippo.com that's the best Kratom on
the planet you're welcome now let's get
back to the program and when it comes to
pound for pound
I my argument would be Islam's not the
number one pound for pound not yet
because pound for pounds all subjective
depending on your criteria is who is
going to be your number one
the number one thing to me would be
strength of schedule and your your your
Reign at that
division how how long were you dominate
who have you beat strength the schedule
how did you beat them
well the number number one
no matter if you have Islam or
valkanovsky it doesn't really matter
because a guy named Jon Jones is back
he's your number one I'd love to hear
the argument for it you're only arguing
why you wouldn't have Jon Jones dump
number one pound for pound is because
the PD accusation outside that there's
really no argument this is side Sealed
Delivered easy get rid of the PD stuff
the accusations just take that out of it
Jon Jones by far rain strength schedule
finishes and then when he comes back to
heavyweight which we know he's coming
back March 4th we have a fight campaign
for a cal bass fight companion with
jelly roll rampaging a very special
guest but that's on thick boy no big
deal but
there's no argument there it's that's
your
that's that's your pound for pound
number one but let's say take John out
of this pound for pound two Shred the
schedule dominance
if you go straight to schedule between
Islam and
volkanovski's strength of schedule's
been tougher he's been champ he's rained
longer at Champion longer but there you
go yeah but they fought Head to Head
they did but can you tell me that if
volkanovsky
was a true 55er and he was this so pound
to me equals like this if Islam if
Islamic juvenile don't enter Alexander
volkanovski with the exact same size
true size let's say Mark Jeff walks
around I don't know they say he gets
from 190 it says 180 let's say vocalypse
see what the exact same they cut down to
55. they're the exact same size you're
telling me pound for pound skill for
skill my chest more talented than
bokonovsky
nope not a chance no chance
volkanovsky showed more skilled
volkanovsky showed showed more technique
and in the exchanges even on the feed I
thought volkanovsky and it's clear
landed more but because he's not as big
it didn't do as much damage but if
they're the same size he would have
finished them so the pound for
pounding's a little dicey I think it's
weird to put Islam over volkanovsky
again based on strength and schedule so
this vertex scorecard yeah verdict MMA
which does it digitally globally too
globally too had vocalovski win the
fight yeah
so they gave vocalovski the second round
which I agree with the third round
that's clear the fifth one clear as day
yeah
clear as day yeah I think we all agree
on this too I think we all think vocal
one you think Vogue one I definitely do
yeah yeah and he wouldn't that fifth
round 10-8 you know
it was the most significant punch in the
fight that dropped them then for
volkenazi end up on top
you know
it's it's
again
you know I think when
when Izzy went up and attempted
greatness and tried to become a double
champ from uh middleweight to light
heavyweight
he was super compromised with the height
there the the not only the height but
the weight with fighting a young uh
blockovich like that's a tough tough
task
he lost a little bit of his kind of star
power doing that but he came back right
now he's lost to Pierre I still think
he's okay there
Alexander volklowski is a guy where he's
gotten bigger from this more people root
for him more people saw his heart now
you now you realize how talented
volkonovsky is that 45 listen we're all
high in yair Rodriguez right now there's
not a [__] 45er that's ever lived who
can beat Alexander volpanovsky you're
out of your [__] mind if you think
any other 45er that's ever lived could
come up to 155 and do well against Islam
make Jeff and make it a controversial
split [__] decision
and most people think you well not most
but a lot of people think Alexander
volcanovski won that fight during a one
145 that's ever stepped inside any cage
on any planet in the history of time
that could have gave Michael Jeff that
much of a fight and you think Yaya
Rodriguez is going to beat him at 45.
you're out of your [__] mind nobody's
gonna be about 45 ever
ever he's a Grace 145 of all time hands
down no argument that 55 I think for
islamachev people always he he showed
that he was human
kind of you know he did win the fight
he's not my pound-for-pound goat because
he hasn't been doing it long enough at
this high of a level he can definitely
become the pound-for-pound goat it's
gonna take a long time to you know take
uh Jon Jones down from that pound for
poundless but
um you know uh Dustin Porey fancies
himself against Mark Chev uh his
takedown offense is really good he hits
like a Mack truck we do see but I think
what we did learn is Mark Jeff
striking's pretty [__] good he's not
like khabib where you know he might
surprise you with some striking I think
we realized when mock Joe was forced to
strike he's pretty [__] good high
level Striker you know
um but I would like to see him against
Dustin Poirier I think both these
gentlemen are just when they fight
you're getting a fight like this give me
clothes like this I do think if they
rematch eventually we're not gonna see
anytime soon if they do rematch
eventually you're going to get a much
different fight because now they have
respect for each other now Mark Chef has
respect for volcanovsi's grappling he
has respect for his size he has respect
for his height he has expect in all
those areas when going into Saturday
night he did not I paid a price for it
that's what made the fight so close on
the other end of that volganovski now
has uh earned the respect
um grappling but he also needs to
respect Market chavs striking Mike
Cheves no punk when it comes striking
he's not compete the Duke could actually
strike so you're gonna get different
fight that's a tough one to call if it
does happen
but at the respective weight classes
volkanasi ain't losing at 45. machachev
ain't losing at 55. now Dustin poorey
does pose some problems for makshev
there
um it'd be a it'd be a closer fight but
machev at 55 probably ain't gonna lose
we'll probably see him go up to 70.
volcanovski at 45 ain't gonna lose not
gonna happen and I think if machev
eventually who knows how long it's gonna
be did go to 170 and there's a I don't
know who on that list not named beats
Alexandria at 55.
so if he did I think it's just a matter
of time before vocalypse becomes a
double champ with my chef there tough
fight for him for sure but
um I think volcanovsky will become a
double champ especially if Mark Jeff
were to leave him go to 70. let's take
another little break guys forget back
the breaking down UFC 284 this episode
the shop show is also brought to you by
on it supplements I'm here to talk to
you about not just Alpha Brain but a
special kind of Alpha Brain I'm talking
about the Black Label that's what I use
it's a premium Alpha Brain line Black
Label is Reef refined formula that
promotes mental processing speed laser
focus for extreme product productivity
Alpha Brain Black Label is Alpha Brain
on that acai it is the ultimate
nootropic to get you going when you need
to get going it's for the big boys out
there we're talking about Alpha Brain
Black Label everybody's taking the
regular nootropic just the regular Alpha
Brain it's great but but when you're
like me and you're an intense individual
you want everything intense that's why
Alpha Brain Black Label is for the few
out there it will get you going it's
Alpha Brain on
turbo juice you thought I was gonna say
something else I'm not gonna do that
Alpha Brain Black Label is the only
Alpha Brain I use I like the other stuff
I start there but sometimes you put your
big boy pants on that's why I go Alpha
Brain Black Label you can save tempers
off Alpha Brain Black Label regular
Alpha Brain if you want to use the shots
those are fantastic the Alpha Brain
instant you just put an eight ounce of
water that's all that's good I before
prefer intense stuff like Alpha Brain
Black Label you can save 10 off
everything when you go to audit.com
you save 10 for the entire website
protein powders all the alpha brains
Black Label instant the instant shots
the regular uh Alpha Brain but if you
want to save temperature the best
nootropic on the planet the most intense
that's Alpha Brain Black Label save ten
percent off your freaking nude new mood
total gut health digestive Tech joint
oil krill oil protein powders all the
equipment they offer they're the best
man audit.com
for life now let's get back to the
program Naples see this weekend Thursday
Friday Saturday Naples Florida get to
get that thick boy.com or fatkz.com
that's this Thursday Friday Saturday
Naples Florida call me off the hook come
get you some and then Bakersfield
California one night one night only one
show February 23rd Brea California March
3rd two shows one magical night because
March 4th we have a fight companion so I
limited down to two shows Friday night
March 3rd in Brea California Bray improv
but Naples Europe this Thursday Friday
Saturday Bakersfield Brea get you some
yeah so I think either way
um you know marketev now here's what's
interesting is Dan hooker has been
tweeting out oh yeah he said you thought
you could go to Australia and we
wouldn't find out you cheating dog I
assume it's reference to makshev of
using an IV which is illegal yeah
so I would assume the UFC looked into it
so there's a series of tweets that he
did so hooker says dumb uh c word things
can fly to Australia hire a nurse to
give him an IV and we won't find out
cheating dog it was like interesting he
says uh
who started doing [__] all yeah wow and
then because and then he puts this
article of a you know UFC fighter space
up to your suspension for IV use and
then
prove me wrong bet you can't otherwise
he's jumping around
um so then he goes yeah since it was
dead who are you talking about it's
early East Coast USA so it's hard to
find out scroll down
he goes wait so let's go here he doesn't
she doesn't win then that guy does this
and he goes Islam is a cheat interesting
uh and then also I saw this from
brawl season Instagram they showed the
three fight pictures I don't know how
legit this is I looked at other pictures
I couldn't find anything so it looks
like there's like a little it looks like
he had something pierced into his inside
elbow area where you would get an IV
yikes one of the ufcs can do anything
about it
if they find out that he did I don't
know how they can like investigate it
though if I don't know how that works I
I don't either they have to look into it
though yeah
weird that you stay in Russians cheating
and I heard of such a thing
um
how would that change your perspective
chin
are you dehydrated would it yeah big
time if you're if you're cutting that
much to like you're draining your body
that much we did IV yeah and then I
don't have an IV that that is kind of
like a performance enhancing 100 IBM
yeah fear point
that's why it's illegal yeah you can't
do it yeah let's go to 170 if you have
to have an IV to make 55. so he's
replenished right away feeling healthy
feeling good it's not good I think IV
should be illegal but they're not so if
it's legal for everyone then that's fine
that's what I'm saying it should be but
they're not so it's definitely an
illegal action uh but we don't know this
is even real true yeah it just
definitely puts a cloud over much of
much of posts on History goes Australia
you mad with a smiley face
so Alex did this post
uh put this just watch the fight I
definitely think I won two three and
five surprised I didn't get my hand
raised let's do the rematch anywhere
anytime and then Islam just watch the
tape have to be fair I have 25 minutes
vote got the last one minute
that's how listen both these guys should
be handled this way in the Press I want
to fight I want to fight the you don't
want to be like no I actually lost no no
no because volcanovski Inside the Cage
was pretty cool about it but it was
great his team was like hey dude you won
that fight we need to let everyone know
yeah and this is Nate Diaz responding
they put congrats Alec voganovsky they
put yeah right Islam got his ass whooped
I think the majority of people do agree
with that though not asking I don't
think the majority the majority like
most like Biz being who's the
commentator and who we respect a lot
here uh a lot of a lot of people Luke
Thomas A lot of people I respect a lot
get give it to uh oh like actual people
in the game legit people fans and stuff
like that not too many people in the
game give it to volkanovsky
um okay well
did though I mean you guys all but we
all did I was watching it when I was
drinking no I re-watched it still I was
like I can see how I came to a
conclusion yeah it's not
it's not like far-fetched
this was kind of funny because Conor
McGregor tweeted this I this I I believe
this is before the fight happened
pound-for-pound waffles wafflers and
then afterwards he tweeted this that was
a great fight last night Lads no loser
they're just winners the Ozzie and the
Aussies showed out and I [__] love
seeing it Perth looks [__] tasty too
now I see why so many Irish are there I
should have went out former titles on
the line congrats all
whoa that was a great fight last night
Lads no losers just winners in my eyes
it's like well up and down hot and cold
oh so this one I thought was interesting
too uh I
I forgot where I saw this first it might
have been from fight and MMA uh whatever
Mafia but it says this is Ali Abdel Aziz
after Islam won he's con he's calling
some people racist because they think
that volkanovski won against Muslims he
sees the races against Muslims oh yeah I
mean people are gonna try and go for
whatever but it's not the case all right
it's just that we think vulcanovic won I
mean yeah I don't give a [__] it up yeah
so that was kind of weird that you
posted this
but it's the narrative right it's the
same thing with Left Right fighting
teams everything like Philadelphia
sworn's waking up going oh if if they
didn't have that holding call we would
have won no that punt return [__] you
they returned all the way down to the 10
or whatever that really screwed you guys
um uh did you watch I just I don't watch
the Super Bowl but I mean I saw the
Chris Stapleton national anthem you saw
that that was freaking that's it right
yeah I hope it was like not lip synced
but who knows I doubt it I doubt it too
no no one lip sings the national anthem
no they did that's funny rude really
even the Whitney Houston one that was
amazing it was lip sync no yeah that's
what I heard I gotta look it up again
just to make sure you sound like a hater
right now she was amazing though uh so
this uh I was talking to you before the
show so Jake Paul versus Tommy Fury uh I
didn't realize it's on Sunday and it's
in Sunday morning Sunday morning yeah
what day February 26th
so it's 2 p.m Eastern 11 A.M Pacific
in Saudi Arabia and the price is going
to be 49.99
it is yeah that's a normal price an
inflation all right
I'd like to if I could pay for that
we'll see if we can get a squad together
let's do it I mean Jake knocks him out
under four
yeah I think Jason went to
yeah our dude George Lockhart he's uh
he's doing the meal prep stuff for Tommy
Fury oh really yeah
it's too bad for him
I like George yeah he's great
uh so Jose Aldo also had a boxing match
over the weekend he won by points and
then since then I guess he's been in
talks with Floyd Mayweather to do an
exhibition bout and in this article he's
saying like it's an exhibition for him
but it's not for me I'm gonna actually
go you know punch him he's gonna
actually try to take his head off yeah
yeah and Floyd's like whoa whoa be cool
man be [__] cool but apparently yeah
Floyd said that what's going down his
side has agreed already my side too
Aldo told mma's fighting uh we're now
waiting for the promoters to get the
deal done wow
you digging that or how do you feel
about it yeah for listen for Aldo I just
want to make all the money I don't know
how much money that makes I don't know
what kind of numbers Mayweather's do at
this point he's fighting YouTubers and
training partners and sure like 20 mil
for the last uh listen If Aldo can make
that much money God bless him I hope he
makes it
all right uh
this is from Charles Oliveira's manager
so I'm not sure this makes my winter
hard yeah so Charles Oliveira versus
baniel Darius set for two UFC 288 and I
you know that that so it's all about
matchups and styles so I think Charles
Oliveira derush
uh great fight all the way around but I
do think it's a tougher fight for Darius
than machjev would be if the same mock
Jeff that showed up to fight volkanasi
brings that the with what Darius does
well it poses a lot of interesting
issues for mock Jeff
for Oliveira for mock Jeff for Market if
because I I think Oliveira has a better
skill set to beat Darius than machev
[Music]
gotcha saw me but for these guys though
Oliveira and yeah that's a great [__]
fight that's exactly what they should be
doing yeah
finally Darius gets someone I know dude
now we just need Hamza to get a [__]
fight at 185. yeah uh this is pretty
cool oh I like this Anthony Smith versus
Johnny Walker their headlining UFC event
May 13th great fight
yep
great fight Finale Fight I think Anthony
Smith gets that done damn yep
and this is also kind of cool
uh Aaron blancheville who's killing it
right now this up and comer she actually
took the place of talisantos who
couldn't fight Jessica andrage because
her cornman couldn't get in for Visa
issues but she's Aaron blacks was
jumping up crazy big in competition to
fight Jessica and Josh
we'll see the main event for UFC Vegas
69 has another change
yeah
yeah that's a big jump up in competition
jump up Jessica is a Savage
um let's go this is another quick one so
Michael Venom page hasn't fought since
uh the Mike Perry fight and bare knuckle
so he's fighting goiti yamiuchi and this
is Mike's record so far
really good except he just lost his
Logan story yeah that's a bummer Split
Decision beat Douglas lemus with
decision and then this is uh
goitiyamiuchi he just beat Neiman Gracie
and that's in Bellator
it's a good fight this one sucks Sean
Brady was supposed to fight Michelle
pajer the it would have been an amazing
fight yeah
UFC San Antonio is looking tasty too
our boy Sean Brady got hurt hurt his
hand I don't know it didn't say exactly
what the injury was
but uh yeah
and I'm sure you've seen this by now
right Deontay Wilder saying he'd want to
fight Francis ingano I don't know and
mmao just do boxing I don't know why
they would do it anyway but either way
for Francis you know Fury's called him
out now that looks like he didn't get
done dude and now with Deontay this is
why he left money flights out yes big
time money fights uh I even thought
about this idea let's make it a two
fight deal everybody always comes the
Box let's do this you come to my [__]
I'll come to yours don't call it [__]
you come to my house come to yours a
true tea party I love the idea I'm a
true warrior Bubba do not do MMA that's
a terrible idea
well I guess it's no different than
boxing it's not like print well but why
does it offer them Francis is Beau
Nichols on the ground compared to
Deontay Wilder the underwater's little
legs it'll be a terrible idea yeah and
last France I guess I'm just gonna stand
with him
you know now I do think Deontay Wilder's
if you're a betting man gives Francis
and boxing the best chance to win he's
still a plus thousand you know
well plus one thousand in boxing
from Ghana plus a thousand yeah damn
because boxing you know but
with Deontay Wilder you know he has that
big right hand which France has seen
before
he hasn't been boxes along his Fury
doesn't have the technique like a fury
or USIC so could do it Anthony Josh a
little more skilled he'd be a plus five
thousand against Anthony Joshua plus 4
000 against Fury and [__] you know yeah
but yeah he's not gonna be a favorite in
any fight but his best chance to win is
Deontay Wilder so I like it and deante
don't do MMA dude please don't
all right so we talked about this last
week Kevin Lee took a picture with Dana
White yeah that's cool now he resigned
with us I love that that's pretty cool I
like Kevin Lee there's some fun fight
for him too for sure and there's another
quick one so Conor McGregor versus
Michael Chandler could be held at
Cowboys oh doggy
it's been interesting what version of
counter we get with this if we force
strength he's doing the ultimate finder
but you're this fight's a ways away huh
and he's gotta get in the freaking
testing pool which I don't think he
still has done yet he will take you side
of Sears at this point
foreign
yeah the ivy thing too like what the
hell yes
um
let's see
oh this was super cool to see did you
guys watch it on there yeah on just over
yeah sick he didn't even realize he's
gonna be inducted into the Hall oh
really he didn't know
then this is his reaction the cameras at
home didn't he didn't think watch
actually so hold on
oh shut the [__] up
shut up are you serious ah let's go
let's get a gold jacket and get his
teeth fixed
it was so different braces adult braces
that get you Doug oh man that's so cute
man God bless him
no way oh man
he didn't know did he
[Music]
oh wait
oh
yeah it's super sweet and just super
sweet ton of Fighters came out just you
know like say it was it was long overdue
he should have gotten a while ago a long
time ago there's a few Fighters they
need to do that for
and it I love it because you know the
belt belt beltor does it but belter
didn't build a lot of those guys you
know so it's not as special it's great
that they're doing it they're showing
recognition to these Legends the UFC
needs a better job of this man for sure
pay it forward dude yeah absolutely
man what a video yeah it's even more
like more crying who's has that posted
on Jens Pulver who I think he does so I
think he does streams with UFC like they
watch the fights like you know to get
you know with fans something like that
I I love Jen's Pulver man yeah he's
great
and this is just straight he's doing
good too for sure and he's working with
UFC doing that kind of stuff so this is
uh Sage Northcutt we haven't seen him in
a while but he's
Jack is he oh my God is that dude is
this Baywatch
he's like humongous now if he didn't
have the Jesus thing going on dude the
[__] only fans might that boy could
make yeah jacking off on there
dude he he's joking yeah yeah man he
looks good
I think that's pretty much it for
current events this shows are good
though yeah that's all good alrighty all
good baby that's it that should be it uh
I'd love to hear it yeah Kevin Hart
promo on there I'd love to hear it if
you think uh Mark Chev won the fight
come debate with me after the shows
don't do it during the show but I'm in
Naples Florida at comedy off the hook
this Thursday Friday Saturday Naples
Florida Bakersfield almost sold out one
night only one show only February 23rd
then Brea California Bray improv March
3rd two shows on Friday night I had to
change my date on the fourth because I'm
doing uh Cowboys fight campaign for the
Jon Jones uh return had to do it had to
had to had to so you got jelly roll you
got Rampage in a very very special guest
March 4th on thick boy YouTube cow
basketball UFC 285 March 4th but March
3rd the night before that Friday two
shows only at Brea Improv then
Bakersfield one night only that's almost
sold out less than 50 tickets left
Naples Florida February 16th through the
18th that's this mother Trucking week
Thursday Friday Saturday Comedy Off The
Hook come get some all right then
Oklahoma City is March 9th through the
11th uh you have UFC this weekend and we
talked a little bit about it but uh yeah
I'm gonna blow your hair back Jessica
and Josh in Blanche field your best
fight on there you know it's got Jim
Miller doing the damn thing against uh
Alexander Hernandez outside that all
good baby
um but yeah I hope you guys enjoyed the
fights love to hear it who you uh who
you thought won
um but yeah Naples see you this weekend
be nice to each other stay thick love
you guys I'm out if you're into thick
boys
like subscribe comment
and God bless America well that's not my
big one just kidding